[音楽]
今から皆さんに一つ聞きたいことがあり
ます
あなたも本プレックスは何ですか
新たにとってコンプレックスはどんな存在
でしょうか
容姿性格体系後口癖
切って多くの人が持っているものでも表に
は出さないっ
もしはまだまだそんなコンプレックスに
悩んでいるとしたら次の1枚の写真を見て
いただきたいと思います
これは私が今年の2月11日 sns に
アップした1枚の写真です
ご覧の通り私のコンプレックスは肌荒れ
でした
今からこの写真が誕生するに至った背景を
少し時間を使って説明させてください
実際時から人前に出るのが大好きで目立つ
の大好き自分大好き
いろんなところに出て行っては学級や生徒
会かと高校時代は演劇部でキャスト
やっぱり今も司会のお仕事など人前に立つ
ことが私らしくいられる瞬間でした
それと同時に思春期の頃から慢性的な
ニキビ体質で気がつけばいつも顔のどこか
にニキビがありました
コッテコテのコンシーラーで隠して隙あら
ば実は潰しちゃったりして自分の精神を
安定させていた
つもりでした
しかしここ一年ほど前でしょうか
ストレスからか自分ではどうすることも
できないレベルで肌が荒れてしまったん
です
街中で他人と自分を比べては私は何で
こんなに肌が汚いんだろうと落ち込み親に
せっかくの魂の外出に誘われても肌荒れ
てるから行きたくないと断る
起きている間ずっと下手したら寝ている間
でさえ
と肌荒れのことばかり考えていましたいっ
ここからさらに負のループは加速していき
ますインターネットの情報に踊らされ化粧
品を買いあさりエステあとサプリメント
美容医療だったりいろんなものを片っ端
から試してみてお財布はちょっと寂しく
なりそれでも肌は治らないむしろその
ストレスでもっと肌荒れしてしまいました
大好きだペト前に出ることも
家族や友人
パートナーに会うことさえ全部いやにられ
ました
肌が汚い
かわいそうな子だと思われるのが辛かっ
心が蝕まれていくのが手に取るように
分かりました
そんな日々を過ごしていく中でふと疑問に
思ったんです
私はどうしてこんなに肌荒れに悩んでいる
んだろう
どっちかっていうとなんで肌荒れてそんな
に悪いものなのっていうちょっと逆ギレに
つか買ったかなと思います
インターネットの広告などでよくあるのが
昔はこんなに肌が汚かったけど今はこんな
うるツヤ肌になりましたみたいな肌が汚い
時期を否定してそれを克服したシンデレラ
ストーリーばかり
でも調べれば調べるほど
シンデレラになる前の時間を愛すべきもの
だと捉えているものってあんまりないこと
に気付いたんです
確かに時間が経てば肌荒れは治るかもしれ
ない
だけど一度荒れてしまった肌は1日2日で
治るものではありません
じゃあその長期戦の間
人前に出てはいけないのか
自分らしく人生を楽しんじゃいけないのか
私は違うと思いました
心霊らになる前の私も私であることには
変わりなくそこには一分一秒同じように
時間が流れているはずなのにまるでその
実況不幸というレッテルを貼り
そして人目を避けてしまう
そんな時間を私はこれ以上過ごしたくない
今この瞬間も私がこれまで過ごしてきた
時間もすべて伊東市私の一度きりの人生
須藤信じたかった
そう思った時私は少しずつ周りの友人に
自分の肌荒れというコンプレックスについ
て話をするようになりました
友人の反応は
全然気にしてないよみたいな感じで私は
正直ちょっと拍子抜けだったんです
これよく考えれば当たり前の事なのかも
しれませんでもそんな当たり前の事が霞ん
でしまうのがコンプレックスの恐ろしさだ
と思います
そして人に話す受け入れられる少しずつ
自信がつく
そんなプロセスを積み重ねていった頃ある
日体調不良からかまたどうしようもなく肌
が荒れてしまったんです
ですが不思議と私の心はそれほど暗くは
なりませんでした
肌が荒れていても人に受け入れられ自分
自身を好きになっている感覚が少しずつ
あったからだと思います
そしてその日々を過ごす中でふと思ったん
です
各こんなに肌が荒れてるんだったらこの
わかりやすく肌荒れてコンプレックスが
あるものをもっと広い世界に出してみたら
どうだろう
sns という綺麗なものが並ぶ世界に
これまで社会が認めてこなかった現象を
のせる
これは面白い
フツフツとした好奇心が湧いてきました
しかしそれと同時に人目を気にしがちで
プライドの高いもう一人の自分がブレーキ
をかけそうになります
汚い
かわいそうな子だって思われるんじゃない
か
アンチコメントくるんじゃないか
自分のプライドもズタボロになるかもしれ
ない
でも私は自分が好きでいられる自分でい
たい
あられというコンプレックスを自分の力に
変えてみたい
もやもやと葛藤を繰り返しながらそれでも
自分らしく生きられる道を選んでみたかっ
たんです
をして誕生したのがこの写真です
肌荒れはバッチリと写真に写っています
でも笑顔
私はコンプレックスがあったって強く
明るく生きていく
これは私にとって自分そして社会やの宣言
でした
この投稿をしてから私にどんなことが
起こったのか
まず私を知ってくれている多くの友人が
温かいメッセージを送ってくれました
それだけでなくこの投稿をストーリーなど
に寄せてシェアしてくれたんです
ノートを行ったインストアライブでは1
時間以上あたにもかかわらず常時たくさん
の方に見ていただき今では約3000回
ほど再生をされているそうですこんな
有名人でもインフルエンサーでもない一
大学生の1時間のおしゃべりが3000回
も流されていることにちょっと恥ずかしさ
も感じながら本当にありがたく思ってい
ます
おおおおおおおおおお
なとひょんなことから防音性形成ネイスの
2000人のオーディエンスの前で話す
機会をいただきそれまで私のことを知ら
なかった多くの方からメッセージを
いただきました
優木は貰った涙が出たいっ
私には身に余るくらいの本当に沢山の
温かいメッセージでした
そして今私が皆さんの前でお話しできて
いるのも肌荒れをオープンにしたおかげ
です
肌荒れてちょっと美味しいななんて思い
始めています
私の実験結果を簡潔に表すなら
コンプレックスをさらけ出したら幸せに
なったということなんです
この一見逆説的に見える流れの中に私は
自分らしく生きるためのヒントがたくさん
隠されていると思います
ここからはコンプレックスにとらわれず
ありのまま
自分らしく生きて生きていくための法則を
3つお伝えしたいと思います
まず初めに私は皆さんにコンプレックスを
オープンにしてみるのはどう
という提案をしたいと思います
俺は別に不特定多数の前に出すことを意味
しているわけではありません
あくまでも選択肢の一つとして家族や友人
パートナーとコンプレックスについて話を
してみてほしいんです
先ほどお話しした3点目一つ目に移りたい
と思います1点目
コンプレックスは自分の偏見を映し出す鏡
である
私が冒頭でお話ししたあなたの
コンプレックス
自分はなぜそれをコンプレックスだと思っ
てしまうのかそして悩んでいるのか一度
じっくりと問いかけてみてください
私が感じてしまっていた肌が汚い
かわいそうな子だと思われるのがつらかっ
た
この肌が汚い=可哀想な子
これって私の中にあった紛れもない偏見
だったことに気づいたんです
社会はさまざまな思惑が渦巻く中でこう
あるべきという偏見を私たちに植え付けて
います
細い方がいいだとかいつも何かにご親切で
いた方がいいだとか肌は白くてつやつやし
た状態の方がいいだとか
もちろんその理想を追い求めるための
ポジティブなエネルギーはとっても輝いて
います
でもそれってしなきゃいけないことじゃ
ないですよね
世界を見渡せば自分がこうあるべきという
理想なんて180度ひっくり返ってしまう
ことなんてざらにあります
例えば私も気にしてるんですけど工場を
っていう褒め言葉
これ欧米であなた小顔ですねなんて言って
もちっとも褒め言葉にはならないそうです
自分がこうあるべきと造り出した理想
そしてその現実との間にある列島かこれを
人はコンプレックスと呼ぶのだと思います
この私たちはある種自分が作ったものに
自分から悩まされに入ってしまうという
ちょっと滑稽な生き物なんです
コンプレックスは自分が偏見を映し出す鏡
そう気づくことが最初のステップです
2点目
コンプレックスを認めそんな自分も肯定し
てあげる
ちょっと見方をこれまでと変えてみ
ましょう
私をはじめ多くの人がコンプレックスは
隠すべきものだと捉えてしまうと思うん
です
それはどうしてでしょうか
理由はいくつか思い当たると思います
コンプレックスを認めたくないだとか
コンプレックスを悩んでるとこ見せたく
ないとかそしてこんな人もいるんじゃない
でしょうか
コンプレックスを見にくいと感じてしまう
自分を認めたくない
これは去っために私がお話しした自分の中
やる偏見ということです
私の場合はそうでしたって肌荒れを見
にくいと感じている自分そして肌が荒れて
しまっている自分
そのどちらの自分にも嫌気がさしまるで
自分が汚く卑屈に感じているように思って
しまっていたんです
毎日を頑張って生きている人であればある
ほどそんな偏見を抱えている自分を認め
たくないそう思ってしまうと思います
そんな人に陥りがちな罠があります
無理やりポジティブまんです
彼は本当にいつもよく頑張っています
周りにもいつもニコニコ優しくて誰よりも
早く動きやっぱりちょっと辛い瞬間があっ
たとしても根性で何とかなると考えそう
あるべきだと感じてしまう
そこから生まれるネガティブな感情に
気づかないふりおうじているんです気づい
てしまえば自分が醜く汚いものに思えて
しまうから
それって本当に恥ずかしいことでしょうか
私も同じようにモヤモヤしていた時ある
女性がこんな言葉をかけてくれましたって
生ごみを押し入れにしまっていても何腐っ
て隠しきれなくなってしまう
その存在にきちんと築いて適切に扱って
あげることが大切なんだよ
この生ゴミというのはあなたが
コンプレックスを通して抱くネガティブな
感情と言い換えることが出来ると思うん
です
皆さん生活の中で生ゴミって出しますよね
これはごく自然なことでそれと同じように
何かと向き合っていれば前向きでいられ
なくなる瞬間もきっとあると思うんです
そこから無理に目を背けることはヘルシー
じゃない私はそう思います
きちんとゴミ箱に捨ててあげてもいいし
巻いて肥料にしてあげてもいい
あなたなりのアプローチで構いません
あなたのコンプレックスにありのままの
感情で寄り添ってあげてください
私は肌が荒れている自分そして肌荒れを見
難いものだと感じている自分をあえて否定
はせず
そんな状態でも朝ちゃんと起きてご飯を
食べて用事があったら外にかけていく
そんな自坊をたくさんたくさん褒めて
あげるようにしました
そして頑張りたい時だけ肌を治すように
頑張る
サボっちゃった日があってもまぁそんな
こともあるよね大丈夫大丈夫と褒めて
あげる
そして人に話すことで受け入れられると
いうプロセスを繰り返し
肌はれている存在は私の一部になっていき
ました
そしてこのプロセスなんと心理学の分野で
も裏付けられていることがわかったんです
セルフコンパッション
というものです
エルフは事故コンパッションは強化や理解
ひと言で言うと自己への思いやり
自分に思いやりを向けることを経て初めて
いたにに思いやりを向けることができると
いう価値観に基づいています
でもこれすぐにやろうと思ってもちょっと
難しいと思うので今から一つ言い方葉をお
伝えします
今あなたと同じコンプレックスに悩んで
いる人が目の前にいたときあなたはどんな
言葉をかけますか
まずはその言葉を自分自身にかけてあげて
ください
無理やりポジティブバーになる必要は一切
ありません
大切なのはありのままの感情に寄り添い
それを認めてあげた後でその感情を紹介し
てあげることです
ゆっくりと
生ゴミとセルフコンパッションというこの
2つの概念を通してコンプレックスを認め
そんな自分を肯定してあげられるコツを
少しでも学ぶ分かって頂けたら嬉しいです
3点目
コンプレックスを自分の可能性に変える
ここまで私はコンプレックスをどう扱うか
そういったテーマでお話をしてきました
マイナスであるものをできる限りゼロに
近づける
しかし私コンプレックスが更なる可能性を
持っているものだと気づいてしまったん
です
先ほどセルフコンパッションの概念でお
話ししたように
自己へ思いやりを向けることを経て初めて
そして思いやりを向けることができます
あなたが悩んできた時間はそしてあなたと
コンプレックスそのものは丸ごとあなたと
隣の人をつなぐ架け橋になると思うんです
私はコンプレックスを発信することを通し
て同じ悩みを持つ多くの方からメッセージ
をいただきました
そしてコンプレックスを発信し続けること
で肌荒れは私の一部になっただけでなく
個性に変わっていきました
今でも見れば分かる通り私肌とことが
ニキビが出来てたりして荒れているんです
でもニキビができたらそれをコンテンツに
して例えばストーリーに乗せてみてこの
ニキビ名前つけてみてくださいって言うか
んってちょっと扇の音たりしてみたりとか
自分の個性としてコンテンツとして皆さん
とコミュニケーションは楽しい死んでい
ます
これも全部
肌荒れてるコンプレックスが私にを垂らし
てくれたことなんです
コンプレックスは他社共感を呼び
そんなパシャと一緒にありのまま幸せに
なるためのツールと捉えることができると
思うんです
これが私がコンプレックスをオープンにし
てみるなどという一番の理由です
肌荒れが私にありのまま自分らしく生き
そして誰かを幸せにする方法まで教えて
くれたんです
これは私だけではなく誰にでも起こりうる
ありふれたストーリーです
今私はもう一度あなたに問いかけたい
あなたにとってコンプレックスとは何です
か
もしあなたがコンプレックスに悩んでいる
としたら
この写真の存在を尽くすでいい思い出して
みてください
人に話せないと思っているほど辛い
コンプレックスがあったとしてもその存在
にきちんと築いてそんな状態の自分を認め
寄り添ってあげること
そしてそれは自分だけでなく他人も含めて
丸ごと幸せになるそんなエネルギーを秘め
ているということ
シンデレラになる前のどんな瞬間もあなた
の人生な大雪の一瞬だと思うから
コンプレックスを可能性に変え自分らしく
幸せになる
そんな昨日までとは違った一日を今日ここ
から一緒に作っていきましょう
コンプレックスに悩むすべての1人今日の
このトークをふさげます
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[音楽]